[Musica]
pensate alle vostre passioni
pensate alle passioni che hanno
arricchito o che stanno arricchendo la
vostra vita e che stanno caratterizzando
il nostro vivere quotidiano
pensate alle vostre passioni e provate a
chiudere a chiudere gli occhi pensando
ad ogni singola passione che state
coltivando io sono sicuro che riuscirete
perfettamente a visualizzare il momento
in cui è nata questa passione
il luogo dove è nata questa passione le
persone con le quali eravate una delle
mie passioni nasce nel 1994 la ricordo
perfettamente e in particolare era
pasqua del 1994
io ero su una spiaggia a sanremo
lasciate si chiama i tre ponti ero con
la mia attuale moglie ea un certo punto
da una scaletta che dalla strada porta
alla spiaggia
vedo un ragazzo con un qualcosa sotto il
braccio era una tavola da surf e il mio
primo pensiero è stato ma dove sta
andando quel matto
ho avuto una sorta di epifania perché
quel matto è sceso in spiaggia si è
messo la tuta ed è entrato in mare
chi fa surf e dice entro in mare chi
invece fa sport d'acqua con la vela
solitamente dice esco il mare e questa è
una prima profonda differenza fra chi fa
surf e chi magari fa skype piuttosto che
i windsurf perché è un'epifania perché
in quel momento il surf è entrato nella
mia vita e ha iniziato a caratterizzare
per una buona parte per alcuni anni la
mia vita era in quella situazione in cui
io coltivava una passione e magari
qualcuno che mi vedeva da fuori diceva e
pensa questo è un ossessionato perché
tutte le vacanze surf musica punk rock
surf ovviamente letture riviste di surf
tempo libero software
ho imparato alcune cose da questa
passione
la prima cosa che ho imparato è stata
non giudicare mai le passioni le
ossessioni e le fisse degli altri la
seconda cosa che ho imparato e ho
imparato a vedere le spiagge e il mare
in maniera completamente diversa
la terza cosa che ho imparato è che c'è
una profonda differenza fra essere un
surfista e fare surf mi sono accorto col
passare degli anni che non poteva
appartenere alla prima categoria
apparteneva alla seconda categoria
quelli saltuari quelli che solitamente
il weekend scendo da milano più dalle
città tristi e cercano di trovare
attraverso ovviamente le previsioni
metereologiche le condizioni migliori
per fare surf progressivamente il surf è
diventato un onda retrostante della mia
vita che mi ha aiutato molto in un altro
momento un altro incontro anzi in questo
caso un re incontro nel 2003 era un
periodo molto complicato della mia vita
professionale ho reincontrato un mio ex
collega
si chiama ernesto ciorra che un poeta e
che mi ha presentato la sua iniziativa
professionale la sua nuova iniziativa
professionale
allora si chiamavano newco adesso le
chiamate e le chiamiamo start up ed era
una newco un'idea sull'innovazione
era un'idea del creare un'azienda una
società che lavorasse sull'innovazione
ho raggiunto ernesto qualche anno
successivamente e abbiamo cercato di
creare un'azienda che aiutasse le altre
aziende a essere innovative ea fare
innovazione progressivamente abbiamo
l'abbiamo riempita di contenuti da soli
non si fa nulla abbiamo trovato delle
persone che come noi credevano in questo
progetto e progressivamente abbiamo
lavorato in modo tale che questa piccola
onda che era un'idea
una nuova azienda diventasse qualcosa di
assolutamente autorevole nel patrimonio
nello spazio dell'innovazione ma
lavorando sull'innovazione e
progressivamente ci siamo resi conto che
l'innovazione non è solo fatta di
persone non è solo fatta di opportunità
e non è solo fatta ovviamente di
tecnologia ma è fatta soprattutto di
spazi ci sentivamo che lo spazio era una
componente fortissima nel determinare le
dinamiche e le regole di innovazione e
allora nel 2015 abbiamo creato uno
spazio per l'innovazione
l'abbiamo chiamato spazio di coop
thinking
l'abbiamo chiamato spin spazio
innovatori innovazione poco creativo ma
questo spazio ci ha consentito di capire
che le persone all'interno di spazi
giusti lavorano in maniera corretta e
tutto quello che circonda le persone a
una fortissima influenza su come le
persone interagiscono fra di loro
e siccome le persone utilizzano le
proprie competenze per metterlo a
disposizione di altri abbiamo iniziato
ad aprire il nostro spazio ovviamente a
ai nostri clienti e non solo è
progressivamente ci rendevamo conto
andando nelle aziende che le aziende non
avevano degli spazi per l'innovazione e
che progressivamente questo tema dello
spazio innovazione iniziava a diventare
centrale nel nostro lavoro
ho incrociato una scienza che non
conoscevo che si chiama prossemica la
prossemica nasce nel mondo della
comunicazione
la prossemica è la scienza che studia
come gli spazi e come le distanze fra
gli esseri umani influiscono nella
dinamica nelle regole e nei
comportamenti
tra le persone e quindi mi sono dedicato
a capire ea cercare di identificare
quale fossero quei territori e quelle di
nano
più favorevoli all'innovazione ai sono
reso conto anche di un altro fattore
ovvero che la tecnologia il digitale
generalmente inteso sta cambiando la
nostra concezione di spazio e sta
allargando la nostra concezione di
spazio e soprattutto stanno aumentando
tutta una serie di ricerche e di
letteratura che sta cercando di capire
come lo spazio che noi consideriamo
digitale sta diventando e sta
influenzando il nostro spazio fisico e
quindi esiste una prossemica esiste una
prossemica della tecnologia che sta
cambiando il concetto di spazio occupato
gli oggetti occupa lo spazio
progressivamente siamo abituati a
oggetti che occupano meno spazio ma la
prossemica e la prossemica
dell'innovazione sta cambiando non solo
gli oggetti nella sua nella loro
concezione di spazio occupato sta
cambiando il modo con cui noi
interagiamo con la tecnologia e quindi
siamo passati progressivamente dallo
schiacciare tasti o girare le vette
butei bulloni a fare così
quindi a fare lo swipe sul telefono fino
e arriveremo a utilizzare la nostra voce
per utilizzare la tecnologia e quindi
anche in questo caso lo spazio della
tecnologia e dell'inter relazione che
noi abbiamo con la tecnologia sta
cambiando e sta cambiando anche il modo
con cui noi viviamo i nostri spazi con
cui noi viviamo di spazi quotidiani e
anche in questo caso la tecnologia sta
cambiando il modo in cui noi intendiamo
lo stare insieme negli affetti familiari
sta cambiando il modo col quale noi
progettiamo gli spazi sta cambiando il
modo con cui noi scambiamo le competenze
o dirigiamo persone perché la tecnologia
e nello stesso tempo un contenuto un
mezzo ma è soprattutto un strumento di
competenza
sta cambiando il modo con cui noi
occupiamo gli spazi pubblici e non sta
succedendo nulla di nuovo
siamo solo cambiando lo strumento con
cui occupiamo lo spazio lo spazio anche
fatto di persone che interagiscono fra
di loro e quindi anche in questo caso lo
spazio sta cambiando sulla della
tecnologia sta cambiando lo spazio con
cui noi utilizziamo la stessa tecnologia
per scambiarci informazioni o per
lavorare insieme agli altri sta
cambiando il modo con cui noi arriviamo
a dare il merito e il credito questa è
una jeep che ho creato da una puntata di
black mirror ai miei studenti ai manager
che incontrano della mia attività
lavorativa sto consigliando non tanto di
comprare i libri di management ma di
guardare black mirror perché black
mirror è il miglior libro di management
sulla tecnologia che in questo momento
abbiamo a disposizione
ma se la tecnologia cambia territori e
dinamiche sta cambiando le regole ei
comportamenti e allora avuto modo di
mettere insieme due delle mie passioni
di mettere insieme una passione per il
surf che latente e la passione per
l'innovazione e mi sono accorto quante
regole che appartengono allo stare in
mare in mezzo alle onde alla fine
appartengono e caratterizzano anche il
modo di vivere l'innovazione e di fare
l'innovazione qualche considerazione
qualche regola che volevo condividere
con voi sia nel soft che
nell'innovazione ci sono le onde non
esiste grafico sull'innovazione che non
sia fatta a forma di onda e quindi
sicuramente si lavora sul sullo stesso
contesto si lavora sullo stesso soggetto
sicuramente ci sono i piccoli unicorni
che nascono da lontano e che
caratterizzano le grandi onde
dell'innovazione altra considerazione è
che la cosa più difficile non è fare
innovazione o essere innovativi
l'aspetto più difficile e acchiappare
l'onda e riconoscere l'innovazione
quando nessuno sa che quelle
quell'effetto quell'evento
quell'opportunità quell'idea diventerà
innovazione e se qualcuno di voi ha
provato a fare surf sa benissimo che
remare era cosa più difficile da fare
un'altra considerazione e che
fondamentale sia per la passione per
l'innovazione del che la passione per le
onde l'allenamento lo studio delle
condizioni sono due rettore requisiti
che non potete abbandonare chi fa
innovazione ha una profonda conoscenza
del territorio in cui deve fare
innovazione e continuamente deve
allenarsi perché se non si allena perde
il contatto col territorio stesso
le tempeste generano le grandi onde e
quindi la famosa considerazione che
nelle grandi crisi c'è la grande
opportunità e una verità assoluta
tale per cui l'elemento fondamentale è
l'adattamento alle condizioni chi fa
innovazione chi è innovativo a una
profonda capacità di adattarsi alle
condizioni che lo circondano
anche in situazione di tempesta avete
sempre chi vi guarda dalla spiaggia e
avete sempre chi vi dice sei un matto
avrete sempre chi vi dirà non ci
riuscirà mai a vetere sempre chi vi dirà
come ho detto io quello un matto
non fermatevi non sottoponetevi al
giudizio altrui e non crediate che fare
innovazione o essere innovativi sia una
delle attività più semplici che possiate
fare i migliori sbagliano
non voglio entrare nella
della letteratura e nella narrativa
dell'errore perché non ci credo molto
alla narrativa che è bello sbagliare
perché poi quando siete in azienda o
siete nel mondo reale
vi assicuro che lo si scrive sulle slide
lo si dice ma poi praticarlo è molto
molto più complicato
la considerazione è che tutti possiamo
sbagliare e il prima la prima regola
dello sbagliare secondo me e non
prendersi troppo sul serio
è una lezione che cerco anche di portare
in giro nella mia attività quotidiana
l'ironia è una delle competenze più
sottovalutate come mi ha scritto
stamattina una persona su su linkedin
rispettate sempre l'ecosistema
rispettate sempre le persone e gli spazi
che vi circondano e l'ecosistema in cui
voi potrete fare innovazione e
l'ecosistema che determina alla fine il
vostro successo per l'innovazione e
infine sappiate che partecipate e
appartenente a una tribù come vi ho
detto prima io ho avuto la
consapevolezza del corso della mia vita
di non poter appartenere alla tribù del
surf ma fortunatamente mi viene
riconosciuto e cerco di essere nel modo
migliore un appartenente della tribù
dell'innovazione e allora ho cercato di
pensare come la tribù dell'innovazione
viva lo spazio e soprattutto quali
possano essere gli spazi della tribù
dell'innovazione e ci sono quattro spazi
principali quattro spazi che determinano
il vivere della tribù dell'innovazione
il primo spazio e lo spazio del talento
e lo spazio in cui chi è membro della
tribù dell'innovazione deve consentire
soprattutto a chi è più bravo di se
stesso di poter coltivare il talento di
poter mettere a servizio della tribù il
proprio talento e le proprie competenze
il secondo spazio e lo spazio
dell'intelligente
l'intelligenza e la capacità
dell'intelletto di riconoscere di
mettere in fila i dati e di riconoscere
le verità verso ciò che non è verità e
soprattutto l'intelligenza e la capacità
in questo momento all'interno della
tribù dell'innovazione di astrarsi e di
cercare di andare oltre
dal nostro pensiero cognitivo lineare e
cercare di integrare il nostro la nostra
capacità cognitiva lineare con una
capacità cognitiva che a me piace
chiamare verticale in questo momento la
tribù dell'innovazione ha il compito di
fare dei salti in alto per ovviamente
cercare di portare chi pensa linearmente
su un'altra curva di pensiero su una
curva di pensiero che ci consenta in
questo momento di capire la realtà in
maniera differente terzo spazio
ovviamente lo spazio della tecnologia ma
la tecnologia come abbiamo visto è il
mezzo con il quale noi impattiamo i
comportamenti
la tecnologia i comportamenti creano un
un'interazione uno spazio
un'intersezione in cui in questo momento
noi non sappiamo più se sono i
comportamenti a impattare la tecnologia
o se la tecnologia impattare i nostri
comportamenti e sicuro che sta
succedendo qualcosa ed è sicuro che
progressivamente chi appartiene alla
tribù dall'innovazione deve riconoscere
prima degli altri la capacità dei due
fattori di influenzarsi l'ultimo spazio
e lo spazio dell'azione la tribù
dell'innovazione è una tribù del fare e
la tribù del fare innovazione non è solo
la tribù dell'essere innovativo chi
appartiene alla tribù dell'innovazione
alla necessità di agire alla necessità
di creare lo spazio dell'azione alla
necessità di impattare la realtà
solo così la tribù dell'innovazione
riuscirà non solo a produrre degli
effetti ma riuscirà soprattutto ad
aprirsi verso l'esterno
perché
di tributi vive ma di tribù si può anche
morire se a un certo punto questi
quattro spazi risultano essere intro
flexi verso se stessi questi spazio
questi quattro spazi una volta creati
devono aprirsi all'esterno grazie
[Musica]